on parle donc du MPEP 78 à présent ce
mouvement politique d'éducation
populaire avec Patricia Saint-George
bonsoir vous êtes la correspondance la
correspondante locale de ce mouvement
dans le département Jacques Michelet
bonsoir à vous vous êtes élu
d'opposition pcfa etloncour et vous êtes
là car vous avez participé à
l'organisation du dernier rendez-vous en
date de cette organisation au début du
mois on va en parler dans un instant
déjà Patricia Saint-George un mot sur le
MPEP c'est une organisation politique
extrême gauche c'est ça pas tout à fait
extrême gauche c'est un mouvement
politique d'éducation populaire de
gauche de gaeou bien sûr de gauche
pourquoi bien sûr de gauche ça veut dire
que c'est un mouvement engagé
véritablement oui c'est un mouvement qui
d'ailleurs a d'abord son origine il a
été créé en 2008 il a regrouper les gens
qui avaient participé au Comité contre
le TC en 2005 donc le traité
constitutionnel européen voilà le
référendum qui a où il y a eu une
majorité de
N donc ces personnes se sont retrouvées
un peu sans rien avoir à défendre
derrière puisququeil y a eu Lisbonne le
traité de Lisbonne qui a repris le TCE
on la démocratie a été bien écorché de
l'engagement contre ce traité européenà
c'est ça base la fondation du mouvement
des militants de tous les partis en gros
de gauche des membres d'association des
syndicalistes voilà et on se retrouve
PEP euh alors vous nous disiez justement
ça a été fondé au moment de l'engagement
contre ce traité constitutionnel non ça
été fondé après ça a été fondé en 200 en
tout c'est partie de cette idéelà voilà
c'est partie de ces personnesl qui
c'était une partie de ces personnes qui
s'étaent qui s'étent engagé en tout cas
tout ça c'était avant le le retour de la
gauche au pouvoir en France ça a changé
quelque chose ou pas rien du tout donc
vous êtes plutôt critique de ce qui
s'est fait jusqu'à présent on va pas je
pense s'engager là-dessus euh oui
critique critique de la
politique critique du fait
que TSCG est passé comme une lettre à la
poste enfin ça ça viendra peut-être plus
tard un tout petit peu plus tard dans
notre discussion je voudrais simplement
dire que ce qu'on entend par éducation
populaire pour nous il s'agit pas de
dire les citoyens n connaissent rien on
va les instruire non c'est donner au aux
citoyens les informations qui leur
permettront de se faire une
opinion personnelle ne pas être
conditionné par ce qui se raconte sur
les médias et et voilà voilà pour les
les engagement alors je regardis un
petit peu les objectifs du du MPB c'est
démystifier la mondalisation lutter
contre contre l'emprise du capitalisme
ouvrir la voix à un socialisme du 21e
siècle un socialisme du 21e siècle c'est
quoi tout fait je vous laisse nous
expliquer
ça c'est très
gentil c'est très gentil de de penser
que le Parti communiste peut représenter
ce ce socialisme du 21 siè alors c'est
pas c'est pas ce que j'ai dit je vous
arrête tout de suite j'ai dit que le MEP
en tout cas avait décidé d'ouvrir la
voix un socialisme du 21e siècle ça fait
partie des statut de cette organisation
organisation que vous soutenez c'est
pour ça quee de nous expliquer bien sûr
bien sûr non c'est une c'est un des
points qui nous rassemblent et qui fait
que nous avons coopéré et que nous
coopérons dans l'initiative qui nous
rassemble aujourd'hui le socialisme du
21e siècle pour nous c'est un socialisme
qui va libérer l'humain
euh nous l'espérons partout sur la
planète d'une exploitation absolument
insupportable d'une crise qui ne peut
pas se
résoudre par elle-même au sein du
système du système économique et social
en place à savoir le système capitaliste
il faut l'appeler par son nom euh
mais il est bien entendu que ce
socialisme du 20e siècle est totalement
à
inventer ce qui ne veut pas dire que
nous ne partons de rien bien sûr nous
tenons compte de l'ensemble de de
l'expérience acquise au sein de ce de ce
20e siècle extraordinairement riche même
au travers de ces erreurs même au
travers des drames que ça a
représenté mais ça représente une
expérience extrêmement riche on sait
tout ce qu'il ne faut pas faire je
posais la question tout à l'heure à
Patrician Saint-George qui s'occupe de
de ce mouvement au niveau local au
niveau du département je vous pose la
même question aujourd'hui ce qui est
fait par le gouvernement ça ne vous
satisfait pas il y a un engagement qui
est pris justement aussi le le MP c'est
aussi pour continuer contester agir
différemment proposer autre chose que ce
qui est fait par le gouvernement qui qui
est de gauche également bien sûr oui oui
nous acceptons le terme de gauche de ce
gouvernement socialiste là n'est pas le
problème ce ne veut pas dire pour autant
que nous reconnaissons dans ce qui est
fait nous pensons que bien sûr la ligne
la plus nég que l'on connaissait avec le
gouvernement de droite de Monsieur de
Monsieur Sarkozy est
abandonné pour ces parties les plus
négatives mais par contre il n'y a pas
pour autant et bien un revirement
suffisant pour qu'il y ait un changement
radical de de politique populaire aut
dit en faveur premièrement d'une sortie
de crise il n'y a pas les éléments d'une
sortie de crise avec avec le
gouvernement de Monsieur Holland
aujourd'hui et notre position critique
justement elle porte làd
nous entendons bien nous faire entendre
parce que nous nous sommes de ceux qui
ont permis son élection
et nous pensons qu'il est de la moindre
honnêteté de nous entendre bien sûr le
mouvement politique d'éducation potique
populaire ce n'est pas un parti
politique hein alors ça je pense qu'il
faudit poser la question madame c'est un
parti politique puisque nous avons même
présenté trois candidats au
législative non pas bien entendu avec
l'espoir de se faire élire mais par
parce que c'est une occasion de se faire
écouter par la
population et voilà et vous continuez en
tout cas à mener des des actions des des
débats des conférences au début du mois
le 4 octobre il y en a eu une de réunion
qui était sur le thème à l'origine de la
construction européenne un projet contre
les peuples et les nations point
d'interrogation c'était le thème de de
cette conférence elle a servi à quoi
cette conférence justement alors je je
me permets de de dire quelle est la
position du P par rapport à l'Union
européenne euh nous sommes dans une
crise extrêmement grave ça tout le monde
le sait la France va sombrer
probablement derrière l'Espagne et tous
les autres nous pensons nous PEP qu'il
faut absolument sortir de l'Union
européenne et sortir de l'euro bien sûr
mais une sortie par la gauche
c'est-à-dire pas du tout une un repli
nationaliste comme le prône
une certaine extrême droite on a vu
quelques images de la conférence qui
s'est tenue donc le le 4 octobre
conférence débat qui qui a participé
quelles ont été les les grandes
conclusions peut-être que vous avez pu
tirer les grandes
conclusions est-ce que on peut présenter
la conférencière d'abord allez-y
brièvement allez-y brièvement mais on va
être pris par le temps ensuite
brièvement Annie Lacroix rise est une
historienne de grande
qualité aliste des relations
internationales du 20e siècle et qui
nous a montré que la notion même
d'Europe économique n'était pas récente
qu'elle datait même d'avant la guerre de
1418 qu'elle a été
véritablement non pas mise en place mais
construite dans l'idée dans les années
et que de toute façon c'était une face
c'était pour les États-Unis et les
grandes puissances capitaliste le moyen
d'ouvrir un marché européen et c'est les
axes j'imagine qu'elle a développé lors
de la conférence vous disis on va être
tout même un petit peu pris par le temps
je voudrais savoir s'il y a d'autres
d'autres actions qui sont prévues par le
MPEP 78 alors par le MPEP 78 et le Parti
communiste ça cellule des longcour nous
avons nous sommes engager à avoir ce
genre d'initiative tous les 3 mois c'est
déjà la deuxè qui se solde par une
participation tout à fait intéressante
puisque la première atteignait les 35 40
participants là on a atteint la
cinquantaine juste après juste après les
vacances la mobilisation est à notre
avis tout à fait intéressante nous
espérons bien aller plus loin est-ce que
vous préparez aussi avec ces rendez-vous
des futures échéances électorales non ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas le but ça n'est
pas le but juste justement notre but
c'est l'idée même que nous faisons de la
démocratie de la citoyenneté nous
pensons que on ne peut pas être citoyens
si on n'est pas responsable des
décisions et des réflexions que nous
avons à traiter et cela veut dire qu'en
fait sans un peuple formé sans un peuple
responsable quand j'y formmer je veux
parler tout particulièrement informé et
pas d'une manière univoque et bien il ne
peut pas y avoir de décision
démocratique notre idée est celle-là et
et à partir de là nous pensons que en
fait c cette action de réflexion et de
formation formation parce qu'il y a des
données pur et simples qu'il s'agit de
de s'approprier et réflexion parce que
c'est à partir de ces de ces
éléments objectivement constatés et bien
que peut se développer une réflexion
intéressante et surtout une une
réflexion pertinente que vous allez donc
poursuivre avec des réunions tous les
trimestres vous nous l'avez voilà et ce
qui ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est
que en fait avec le MPEP on n pas
forcément les mêmes positions et c'est
ce qui donc il a débat au sein du MPEP
voilà et ben justement pour pour y
assister je vous invite à vous rendre à
ces différentes réunions merci d'être
venu nous présenter ce ce mouvement
Patricia saint-georgees et puis Jacques
Michelet également qui était avec nous
pour conclure ce plateau du 78 on va
juste passer très brièvement au rappel
des titres de ce 11 octobre quelquesuns
des sujets que nous avons abordé
aujourd'hui les salariés d'ASS sécurité
à Guillan courin qui est le dirigeant de
l'entreprise a claqué la porte il y a 4
mois depuis perçoivent plus leur salaire
la liquidation judiciaire vient d'être
prononcée il a 22 ans il est tiny Montin
et Benjamin du pays que vous allez
apercevoir dans un instant a créé une
petite entreprise plutôt originale un
distributeur de chewinggum qui ne
fonctionne qu'avec des pièces de
quelques centimes autrement dit il
permet à tous de se débarrasser des
pièces rouges vous l'avez vu tout à
l'heure si au lieu de rembourser les
soins la Caisse Primaire d'Assurance
Maladie les prévener l'opération Santé
Active est une initiative départementale
d'abord déployé à poissie le dispos
positif va être testé prochainement à
Saint-Quentin en iveline et puis les
Bleus c'est du foot à l' entraînement à
Clairefontaine avant leur match amical
contre le Japon ce vendredi demain et
surtout avant la rencontre face à
l'Espagne mardi prochain une équipe de
France marquée par l'empreinte du PSG 5
joueurs du club parisien la compose
voilà pour ce rappel des titres le 78
s'est terminé pour aujourd'hui demain
l'édition du weekend vous sera présenté
par Alice Gastine je vous retrouve lundi
sur ce plateau en direct avec de
nouveaux invités nous feront une
nouvelle fois le point sur l'actualité
18h en direct et puis 19h pour la
première rediffusion à
lundi